you know what's interesting there's some
people that genuinely are serial
cheaters
that they thrive off of like that's
their happiness yeah and it's crazy to
me because we don't understand it and
you know like if they find each other
and date each other that's fine just
don't date the monogamous people right
uh i've seen women online that's like
yeah he goes on bubble ball but he comes
home to me
are you proud of this are we not
embarrassed who are you bragging about
yeah you're the shelter yeah you're just
the home that he goes home to but he's
still [ __ ] around they're like no but
he knows who to come home to like
when the sex is gone my body starts
rejecting the sex yeah what used to feel
so good now it hurts
you know like i'm not about it anymore
like
you've never been annoyed by him
i've been annoyed by like i told you
like when he wasn't back through it was
[ __ ] annoying right but you would
never be like a [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of my face right now
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
we are here we got
three whole people here okay there's a
freaking party we got uh who we got
actually who do we have hi it's me gina
and we got our special guest hello
everybody i'm stacey diazapolaka and our
even special or guest me nikki limo so
you're welcome for me being here um
today we thought we would pick a topic
that
our guest is kind of an expert in not to
brag but she is you should follow her on
tick tock and on instagram and on
youtube yes you should because i feel
like this is all the stuff that you talk
about yeah mainly on tick tock yeah this
is what i talk about on tech talk on
youtube is more of my life you know but
tick tock that's it's like what i love
to do why is it different
um i think just naturally the way that
it
went so for example on
on youtube i started sharing things like
this when i first started like i would
talk about relationships but then those
videos didn't really do well because i
feel like maybe the longer content
format didn't work well i see so then i
started sharing my life and people like
that and then on tick tock you have 60
seconds to get right to the point and
then just give you that pep talk and
you're like oh i really needed
yeah um i mean i do have the format in a
second channel if people want it but it
doesn't do as well as like vlogs yeah
yeah because yeah that's so true yeah i
don't know why but i mean it works
versatile i could do it all i think that
because like when you're scrolling tik
tok it's like i was like oh i really
needed to hear that today yeah yeah yeah
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna share this
with my friend or whatever it's easy to
share yeah it's like a little quick pick
me up you know and i feel like this kind
of content when it comes to
relationships and like self analyst
analyzation it takes like sitting
through a 20 minute video is tough yeah
you know sometimes you're like [ __ ] i
don't want to hurt you
yeah like i don't want to hear you tell
me my men is not worth it you know like
for 20 minutes yeah a 60-second one is
like oh man yeah he's not worth it but
i'm just going to keep ignoring you yeah
yeah
scrolling you know
so we are talking about moments that
boyfriends realize that
their girlfriend is not the one and for
a variety of reasons and
in our opinion because i agree with
stacey um and i think you would agree
with me that it's better for them to
tell you yeah i love that we're talking
about the men's side because obviously i
make contact for women all the time i
love women i want you all to know your
worth but sometimes i feel like we like
write off man it's like oh they don't
know but no they know obviously they
know and we're gonna find out why why
they felt the way they felt and their
feelings are just as valid so i'm
excited to
possibly be on their side yeah like all
right sure let's hear the other side of
it you will know for a fact whether or
not she's on their side
i have a feeling immediately
okay so
um this is an article that was actually
posted on buzzfeed and we just sometimes
we run across articles and we think
they're interesting like oh these are
good conversation starters so we might
not get through all of them but i just
thought some of these were
interesting and i think that sometimes
you don't
you tend to think take things really
personally if you're getting broken up
with but sometimes it's just when does
that differently
not take it personally right i mean
you're it's personal it is personal
breaking up with me sometimes it's nice
and a lot like after a while like not in
the moment but when you look back to be
like you know what we weren't a good fit
yeah because i would have had to change
myself or he would have had to change
his self like the core of who they are
yeah when you're in it doesn't feel like
that it does not feel like when you're
getting broken up with
okay so this one he says my last ex
always wanted to go do her own thing and
expected me to just drop my life and go
with her wherever it was if she wanted
to move across the state for a
university she expected me to come along
and get an apartment close by or i could
stay behind with no guarantee it would
work out between us she never asked how
i felt about her plans it was just her
way or no way i always had this feeling
that if i didn't give her attention
every 10 minutes that she'd want to get
it from somewhere else i didn't treat
her wrongly or act as a controlling guy
by any means it was just a gut feeling i
had that i hated
yeah
i wish i knew how old these people were
true if he says go into college yeah
i feel like they're younger yeah yeah
but it's good to know that they have
that self-awareness right off the bat
knowing that like you don't want to
cater
your life to someone else's life like
that like that much yeah big life
changes like that are always tough for
everybody you know especially if one
person wants to stay the other one wants
to go and when you're that young like
you don't know yeah what you want i feel
like i was willing to drop things to do
things for people
i probably wouldn't have but yeah but i
feel like
the fact that he knows and like he's
like what if i want to stay here yeah i
want to go somewhere else or like people
going to different colleges is a huge
reason of why they break up a lot of
times like high school couples and stuff
yeah that's true i guess i've been on
both sides of this but when i moved to
la to be an actor i had a boyfriend that
just moved with me and he didn't have
anything in la he just moved with me to
support and i thought that was really
cool and i was like so stoked obviously
i was like so stoked but then i realized
through years of living here that he
didn't have his own thing he was just
kind of waiting for me to get home and i
was like oh i want to go out and network
with people i want to like you know do
the thing and i wasn't getting romantic
attention from anyone else but he still
felt like my attention was going
elsewhere and so it was sucked on both
sides because it was like
i didn't want to put my i didn't want to
take away from what i was trying to
build but i also
felt like i needed to cater to him where
it like he didn't have his own thing
going on yeah i don't i don't know if
this is an unpopular opinion but i think
before marriage moving away for somebody
like if the only reason why i'm moving
is for you
that doesn't seem very healthy yeah you
know like
not marriage but like a commitment like
we're lifetime partners right like if on
like i there's this creator that she
talked about how she's no longer with
her partner and basically she had a
house and she rented the house so that
she can move closer to where her
boyfriend lives and i'm like
at least she still has that house yeah
yeah i'm just like you move the whole
last thing you know like
everybody gets to do whatever they want
but it's just unless you're like you
have a commitment yeah like i'm gonna
make it work or you're willing to be
that source of entertainment of
friendship like this person was you were
his everything yeah right like that's a
lot of pressure put all the eggs into
this basket and i was like i can't keep
up because
sometimes i was tired and he's like
ready he's like oh i couldn't i waited
all day for you to be honest yeah
yeah
i i learned that you can't date someone
who hasn't who doesn't have their own
thing going on because it's like they
rely on you so much where it's like can
you just go to the other room and have a
hobby yeah
and it even comes down to like not even
big things like moving i remember my
ex-boyfriend
he was a big partier like every weekend
he's like i worked all week i just want
to go clubbing i was like bro we're like
30 something yeah and then i felt like
that person on the article was like i
felt like if i didn't go then he would
seek
attention from someone else yeah and
that's exhausting and very is much
exhausting because it keeps you so
anxious and at the end it did happen i
didn't know and he hit on a girl and
cheated on me yeah you know so you don't
want to be in that anxious situation
trust issues exactly because yeah you
can be everywhere all times
yeah yeah
right kitty like sometimes you make me
do things that i don't want to do very
clingy yeah come here hi so
that
the fact that she doesn't even care
about what he wants like that sucks
that's like how i felt like yeah i don't
want to go out this way it's a maturity
thing for sure like that she didn't even
take his needs into consideration
anything i think he made the right
decision i'm with him i agree with him
she did the right thing we agree with
you dude all right next one is she
invited me over to cook for me and
instead ambushed me with her eight
friends to interrogate my feelings in
their relationships
that's scary
so she's like oh let me come over and
cook for you and then she brings or come
over and i'll cook for you right yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah come over and i'll
cook for you and then instead you're
greeted with eight females asking you if
you're serious about their friend yeah
uh i don't no one likes to be in
territory yeah i don't know but see okay
here's okay
i like a hot cake
hot take um
okay are you being interrogated or were
her friends just hanging out like i'm
somebody who has a lot of girlfriends
like i mean there's like five of us but
like my fiance has never not once been
like i'm being overpowered yeah you know
right
like i feel like if he really liked her
he would have been like yeah i like her
what's the big deal like yeah sure we're
missing some information for sure if he
didn't know that this is gonna he
thought it was he was coming over for a
nice romantic date and then instead you
get eight girls who are all like
asking you a bunch of questions maybe
why does it have to be a big deal like
if he thought like oh my god yeah i'm
gonna come get cooked for and then i'm
gonna get it in and then yeah you know
if he was coming with different plans
and then oh [ __ ] her friends are here oh
i hate it now you know like yes
i think it's like
it was under the guise of something else
like if he she was just honestly like
yeah my friends
are here oh okay you know my friends
want to meet you and like come over and
hang out and meet them all and yeah sure
that's fine i'm sure he would be fine
with that but like if you're if you have
to trick him into it yeah yeah that's
true
here's the other thing is like i don't
know if that would be a deal breaker for
me i might be a little bit annoyed yeah
uh at that point
is the conversation yeah maybe this was
too new too but i will say that that's
one of the reasons that steve broke up
with somebody before was he does not
like when friends are when the
relationship's new like you're just
dating you're not even like boyfriend
girlfriend yet you're just like starting
to date and then the friends are like yo
if you break her heart i'll [ __ ] you up
you know like something like that and he
said that that happened this girl he was
just starting to date he went to a
barbecue with her friends and they
pulled them aside and they were like if
you break her heart we swear to god
we'll come find you like that kind of
thing and like sometimes it's joking but
even in jest he's like you know what
have her i don't [ __ ] want her yeah i
don't want it because i don't want to
even deal with that like you ruined this
not her you ruined this i don't want to
have these friends in my life
interesting
it's true because it's new yeah like if
your friends would have said that he
probably would have been like your
friends are [ __ ] annoying yeah but i
like you yeah i don't know i don't know
like maybe in the beginning if they
would have said that he might have been
mad but he would have talked to you and
been like i hate those friends
yeah like maybe and i'm not saying like
as friends we have to like be protective
of it but like there's so many men that
are so
disrespectful to women and as friends
and as a sister and as everything i've
never had that conversation but i have
had the conversation that's like i'm
anybody has a new boyfriend i'm scared
like i'm looking at him from the
beginning yeah you're being tested yeah
you definitely are being tested at all
times get over it you know
yeah you are and like just how we are
too you know when you're dating somebody
you're being tested when you're coming
into the friend group i'm watching you
mm-hmm
i also think so okay i can get on this
guy's side with the like the way it was
kind of dishonest they're like oh come
over here and yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i do feel that if you're
building a solid relationship with
somebody
communication is how you build it so you
have to have little things like this
where it wasn't cool with you and then
you guys work it out yeah if you didn't
allow her the chance to work it out then
you're right he just wasn't that into
her yeah because i mean like we get it
too when i first met my friend so he has
five sisters the weekend i met him he
took me to his friend's family wow
he's one of the youngest so obviously
all they're all older
and they're all protective of him and
they literally
one of them sat down with me and was
like i just want to let you know like we
love him and i was like as you should
i'm glad he has you guys yeah i was
never like your sister no i was like i
get it i'm glad because he had had a
relationship where he was disrespected
and now obviously they were trusting
somebody new and he was trusting
somebody new so i never saw it as like
oh my god they hate me no i was like i
get it they love you yeah why is that a
bad thing that's great i wouldn't feel i
think that's such a
common thing to do no i wouldn't feel
threatened but then men don't do that
for their guy friends though they don't
pull the girl be like yeah you [ __ ]
my bro yeah yeah
they don't do this
yeah it's such a girl thing to do but to
be very like
bothered by that makes me feel like her
you didn't really like her in the first
place yeah i mean good thing you broke
up with her because you didn't like her
but
yeah i mean grow up you know people are
gonna ask there's gonna be a time where
her parents gonna be like that yeah her
sibling maybe he didn't feel prepared
for it yeah maybe she should have been
more honest yeah my friends are gonna be
here just so you know but a deal breaker
i don't think would be a deal breaker
not for me yeah it wasn't for me
okay so we don't agree with you on that
one dude we do understand but we don't
agree
okay this one it says uh i had an
ex-girlfriend who tricked me into
meeting her parents oh another one
people don't like being tricked okay
yeah nobody likes me i would gladly meet
them if she invited me but she faked a
panic attack so i would take her to her
home and her parents were in on it it
seemed silly but it looked like a sign
of deeper issues so i walked away and
seen the kind of relationship she
developed with other guys after me i'd
say it was the right call no that was
the right call yeah you can't okay this
also comes down to the communication
issue you know you don't trick people
trust issues issues especially faking a
medical thing yes wild yeah and this is
the fact he made it very clear she
tricked me the first guy was like oh i
came over and her friends happened to be
there you know like this was like she
purposefully
like faked a medical issue
yeah and your parents were in on it and
then you're yeah so that's a [ __ ] up
family yeah in general but um you're
you're crying wolf if you do have panic
attacks and and anxiety issues and then
your fate your first one's a fake
like he's never going to believe you
again that you're having a panic i just
wonder how he knew that
he got tricked
yeah
or how he knew that they were in on it
too yeah maybe they said so they're like
oh you know we just oh yeah just just
kidding yeah because of the parents
because how could you be so ballsy to
say that you know if anybody faked a
medical condition as a joke like even
like you know couples do like pranks on
each other on youtube i could never like
i'm not doing that that's not it sounds
like it was kind of a prank like because
he got there and it was like surprise
you know you're meeting us you know oh
that's creepy yeah and it's really
creepy i mean if you want somebody to be
your parents just give time yeah
yeah that's really weird that that would
you would want that to be your first
impress their first impression exactly
wouldn't you want to meet the parents in
like a healthier way wouldn't the
parents want to meet the new boyfriend
in a healthier way like why would they
agree to you yeah because there's a
weird family she was like
you know i want you to meet my parents
and he was like i'm not ready yet or
something like that yeah and if he's not
ready yet that's valid like you got to
respect that boundary
that's a boundary that was broken so
yeah i think that's
yeah you're right on this one that that
was a good call
she sounds crazy oh yeah
if gina's saying she sounds crazy she's
crazy crazy
okay
um oh
someone like responded to this they said
my ex did this to me too she told me to
come hang out with her one weekend i was
like cool a day of watching star trek
good food and some afternoon delight i
showed up and her entire extended family
was there they made me hold a baby i'm
naturally
very awkward around new people so they
all thought i was weird i could tell my
girlfriend wasn't very happy about the
poor impression i made well there's a
reason i didn't want to meet your family
dude that's jesus
people can't throw people in these
situations they need to prepare like not
everyone's just i think you know there's
extroverts and introverts and i think
sometimes extroverts just think
everyone's ready to go on an impulse
like they are but like introverts are
a lot of us are like we need to prepare
we need to like that is so funny because
i'm gonna stand on the other side
i have a big ass family you know and so
for example that weekend that i met my
fiance he was like oh we're having a
family party for blah blah i was like
all right sure let's go you know so to
me a big important thing because i have
a big family and because they're all
loud and because they're all over your
face it's like you should
you i would like to date somebody that's
always ready to be ready you know and so
danny is like that and i'm like that you
know good so when i did take him to my
family's house in mexico everybody loved
them right so i could see like if you're
an introvert and you're dating an
extrovert yeah you definitely need to
let them know yeah yeah yes because i
will be like yeah let's go hang out with
my friends right now like what you need
a day for what
because i'm the same same fam like huge
family filipino family they're all loud
i was the quiet one in the family and
people are like you were the quiet one
but yeah uh
so i i fit in and i can blend into loud
families and also i do stand up for a
long time so like i can i can handle
hecklers and like
things but
if uh if someone if i like have my day
planned and then you throw something at
me last minute i'm really bad at like
rearranging my schedule in my head and
then like i'm all thrown and i'm like i
gotta curl my hair or something like i
need to like look good especially if
it's the first time meeting someone i'm
like i need to like at least look cute
so if i [ __ ] up like they'll be like oh
she's cute still i know stuff like that
so it does throw me i can mask it but
it's like i definitely get thrown by
that yeah i i i just i i am very uh
meeting my parents is such a big thing
you know that only one maybe two
boyfriends have ever met my parents wow
and also because they live far away too
but like i have extended family here
that i'm very close to and it's like i
i would be like no i gotta wait a little
while to bring someone to meet my family
you know so it's like wild to me that
some people were just like hey come here
i'm in the mix yeah yeah yeah yeah i
mean i don't know if i don't know i mean
i just would like to think denny liked
me so much yeah i was like oh come on
yeah um but it was definitely a first
for me to meet somebody's family that
fast yeah sure
uh and when i saw how big the family was
i was like oh but then i adjusted
quickly you know it's kind of like a
change of pace but i caught on
but yeah i've taken friends to my
family's house who weren't as
extroverted and definitely they were
just like in the corner like
now imagine if you tricked them in
because yeah
that's like yeah on top of already being
like socially awkward now you're like i
was not at all prepared but also like if
you're the type of per like one of the
things i love about denny is how easy he
gets along with people yeah i can
literally bring him in here right now
and he would talk to all of you right
and so maybe like if you would see that
you'd be like maybe we're not a match
yeah you know and that's fine and so
that's what i was saying in the
beginning it's like
yeah like if you get broken up with
because of this it [ __ ] sucks and
it's hard not to take that personal but
then in the long run like that's just
not the right match for you yes if that
person's gonna constantly throw you into
situations where
you're not ready for it then you just
that's not a good match yeah yeah it
reminds me of people who constantly have
to do like tests yeah i was just testing
like people don't like being tested no
that's not cool especially if they don't
they didn't deserve it like they haven't
done anything to show that they exactly
weren't
loyal really i think i'm just thinking
about that like i met steve's family
within two weeks of us dating that was
the fastest i've ever met anyone's
family and vice versa too we've met each
other's family within like the same week
when they know and um and i i was not
thrown off at all by that but i did cry
the first time i met them why
um
i didn't have my coffee in time
and
my body just like i wasn't i was so mad
because i was like i'm being betrayed
because my emotions just like whenever
there's too much emotion of any emotion
happiness sadness frustration
anger whatever it just comes out as
crying and then it looks like i'm just
like
crying being dramatic or something but
i'm like i swear like i'm not thinking
any intense thoughts i'm just i just
need coffee physically or else i'm gonna
cry and it just doesn't i'm not trying
to throw a tantrum or anything it just
it's happening and so i tried really
hard to hold it hold it back and they
wanted to go see a movie like right off
the bat and i hadn't had coffee in like
two hours between waking up yeah i just
started crying at the movie theater it
was like i need coffee
yeah nikki emotion wise like happy to
say she has to be in between like a four
and seven anything higher than that
she's crying out of happiness something
lower she's crying out of sadness it's
very true the tears are both ways yeah
there's like a there's like a limbo with
no tears yeah yeah that little sweet
spot
otherwise it's it's kind of lazy oh yeah
exactly right now
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart here's how it
works when you're shopping on one of
your favorite sites at checkout the
honey button appears and all you have to
do is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons it
can find for the site if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop honey doesn't just work on desktop
it works on your iphone too just
activate it on safari on your phone and
save on the go personally i bought um
some chairs recently for my apartment
and i saved i think about 30 dollars
with a honeycomb so that was awesome if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show get honey
for free at joinhoney.com
big mood that's joinhoney.com
big mood women's health is under attack
stay in control of your reproductive
health with birth control and the
morning after pill from favor delivered
straight to your door the service you
know and love as the pill club is now
favor favor provides digital care
prescriptions and products for your
well-being with over four thousand
five-star reviews favor carries over 120
fda-approved brands and ships to all 50
states
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid otherwise
prices start as low as 6.99 per pack
without insurance favorite delivers
birth control to your door for free and
discreet packaging along with fun
self-care extras right now when you go
to hayfavor.com big mood favors offering
a 10 donation to bedsider.org for every
big mood listener who becomes a patient
your donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's
h-e-i-f-a-v-o-r dot
big mood to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember it's hayfavor.com big
mood you must use the link to make a
donation the next one um okay this one
sounds pretty obvious when she asked for
a dude's number at a party while i left
for a minute i caught her in the act and
she still lied about it
if people don't like liars or cheaters
oh my gosh i just don't i see this stuff
as being just more of an
like you're not immaturity
you're not ready for a relationship yeah
yeah you know you know what's
interesting there's some people that
genuinely are serial cheaters
that they thrive off of like that's
their happiness yeah and like some of
them like there's youtube videos on it
that they'll literally say like i just
can't be
monogamous like it's fun for me it
brings the thrill out of me like it's
just i wasn't even gonna text the person
i just wanted to get the number just to
see that i could do it right and it's
crazy to me because we don't understand
it and you know like if they find each
other and date each other that's fine
just don't date the monogamous people
right yeah because that's where it
becomes dude i even know married people
i know this one married person that
he he doesn't even like you said he does
not even gonna cheat but he just wants
to know that he could yeah and so like
he loves that thrill of like
getting their number or like getting
them to like him or whatever because he
just wants to know that he's still got
it it's validation yes his wife know no
yeah see like i wish just tell me yeah
that's what it's gonna be just be
straightforward on this type of person
tell me and then
like there's people that are happily
swinging
and they're
happy with it right do you think though
that part of their thrill is like
getting away with it you know right for
cheaters yes yes so for cheaters like
it's not that they're in love it's the
chemical reaction that you're getting
yeah when you're cheating like you're
it's excitement it's dopamine everything
is like when you were young right when
you were young and everything was so new
and you're like oh i got her number and
like we're texting or whatever
cheating is not love it's an addiction
yeah so yeah like if their partner was
okay with it it wouldn't be as fun yeah
it wouldn't be like they're getting away
with something it'd be like oh okay well
i guess that's so sad yeah that's so sad
i've definitely dated guys like that so
you're really cheaters yeah same yeah
like i remember go ahead sorry we
reconnected off of the fact that like oh
yeah like if you ever wanted to cheat on
me like just tell me and break up with
me first like i don't want to be cheated
on
they're like i would never blah blah i
did that to one girl once and like i
never would do it again and then i found
out they did it to every year they ever
dated and that was my recent
ex-boyfriend like i remember he would
message me while he's in vegas for his
friend's like bachelor party whatever
and he would message me and call me be
like babe can we just never be like this
like
ugh
yeah like he has like two friends one's
married the other one's in a long-term
relationship he's like they went home or
they left with some other girls like
yeah you know like i just never want to
be like i'm so glad we're not like that
exactly while he was cheating on me yeah
or like he'll come home after a night of
clubbing and drinking he'll be like babe
so many girls hit on me tonight ew
but i said no i'm like did you just come
over to brag yeah why would you think i
want to know that's an a and then also
like to set up this picture of him being
like i'm such a loyal yeah exactly so
you're the only one for me
i'm so glad i'm not
on the level of those disgusting
cheaters right right you mean your own
best friends yeah
yeah good to know sooner than later yeah
for sure
i'm glad that you broke up with them at
the number part because my dumb ass was
like oh okay it was just a silly thing
that i misunderstood because i'm being
gaslit and i don't know
oh silly me he just wants validation
it's okay for him to get validation yeah
obviously he didn't do anything he does
this with everyone he's just a fun
loving person
that reminds me of like uh i've seen
women online i was like yeah he goes on
bubble ball but he comes home to me
are you proud of this are we not
embarrassed why are you bragging about
it yeah you're the shelter yeah you're
just the home that he goes home to but
he's still [ __ ] around like no but he
knows who to come home to like
you're feeding a stray cat yeah what are
you doing you don't live there he just
comes there to eat
uh the next one is i started to realize
i was happier when she wasn't around
that one's huge yes that's such a good
flag i know it feels bad because you got
to do the breakup thing but it's it's
good to feel that and know that i don't
body's telling you i wish that we knew
if they were boyfriend and girlfriend or
if they were like married
because i feel like it's
same feeling different circumstance
right like what do you do what would you
guys do i i it's that's hard to say
because in my i've been in a
relationship where
it was the same one that moved to la for
me and stuff where i just realized like
i was really comfortable with him but i
was so much happier when he wasn't home
i felt free i felt like i could do
whatever i want like i could paint and
drink wine and not feel like i have to
do whatever they needed me for at that
second and i realized that i would just
be happier single than with them yeah
and so it was the hardest breakup
because
he didn't do anything wrong
and and i didn't have a thing for him to
work on or anything i was just like i
just know i'm
happier alone
and that was hard but
i i knew from that relationship that i
would never
commit myself to anyone that i ever felt
that way with again so
with steve who i ended up marrying
it's just [ __ ] fun all the time and
there's always something new to discover
with each other and i knew that i needed
to marry somebody like that where we're
constantly discovering new things
together and we're always stimulated by
each other because i could never
deal with that type of breakup again
where i had to be
like not the bad guy but like the bad
guy because they didn't do anything
wrong and now i have to be like yo i
just fell out of love with you and i'm
not i'm happy or alone like yeah i that
that was so heartbreaking to break
someone's heart for nothing that i i
don't know if i could i'm happy i went
through that so that i didn't commit
myself but if i had committed myself it
would be a hard decision because i
committed myself
legally and officially and you're you
know entangled now
with marriage
i would feel a certain obligation to
stay with it but
for your own happiness it's just i know
you know what the craziest it's hard
it's like when people have kids and they
feel bad yeah dude
oh my god that is so tough having kids
is the final lockdown yeah
right and you would think and of course
it's not like you're there forever like
if
something happens you can always leave
but
i wonder if you guys feel this way still
because you haven't had kids
because research shows that when kids
come into the family
happiness goes down it goes back up
after yeah but the initial couple of
years it's tough yeah you're not saying
i haven't heard that it's a new
adjustment your new parents you don't
know how to be a parent and then on top
of being each other's partner
financial resource blah blah blah you're
also now co-parents
so
i don't know like what you would do like
if you fall out of love but that's what
marriage is right like if i'm out of
love like
love is not a constant feeling sometimes
it's up and sometimes it's down like all
feelings sometimes you're happy
sometimes you're not sometimes you're
sad sometimes you're not so when you
marry that you make that commitment to
ride the wave
of
i don't feel that in love right now you
know um so that's why it's like danny
and i have this thing where it's like
i don't care if you love me but you have
to respect me yeah right so like because
there's going to be times where you're
not even going to like me you're going
to be like oh my gosh she's being so
annoying or oh my god he's being so
annoying but we have to respect each
other regardless of that so i feel like
i can't speak on this because that is
how most relationships are and i think
that with steve it's just completely
different
i've never even felt like
a tinge of like oh i don't even like you
right now like not even a little bit but
with every other boyfriend i have and
and i felt like it was natural and i
felt like
forever like if i picked my person like
we're just going to stick it out through
all the good blah blah and i do think
that's generally good advice but i also
feel like sometimes you find someone
that
like
he we like we just even our fights i'm
like oh cool we get to get closer by
solving this together you've never been
annoyed by him
i've been annoyed by like i told you
like when he was back through it was
[ __ ] annoying right but you've never
been like a [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my
face right now
yeah when we're we're fighting and we're
misunderstanding each other for sure
quick and normal please relate
okay i relate to being annoyed yeah
where you're just like get the [ __ ] out
of my face you know how like i still
love him every other boyfriend i've had
i've gone through a phase where i'm like
i don't even know if i like this person
and we're probably gonna break up and i
feel like it's just a [ __ ] battle
when i go see them like are we gonna
fight today i don't know like it's just
you know like every relationship i've
had has had those like and and my
married friends would be like you just
kind of stinking that you're not gonna
find someone that's perfect blah blah
blah and then you think that you're
finding it's not that you're finding
someone perfect it's that you're finding
someone that's willing to find the
language to you with you to work
something out rather than throw sticks
at each other during an argument like
where you're like hey we're being
misunderstanding each other right now
what are you trying to say and i'm gonna
listen to you and i'm gonna be like oh
okay i think i know what you're saying
i'm gonna regurgitate what you said and
this is how i feel about it do you
understand what i'm saying and then he
says it back to me and i'm like okay now
we're on the same page so we can
understand each other and we could still
disagree on something but at least now
we know where each other's coming from
and i can have your back in this
situation and you can have my back in
this situation and because of that
there's never been a resentment that's
built up where i'm like [ __ ] now i gotta
talk to him about this or like oh he's
doing this thing again he doesn't
[ __ ] get it or he doesn't respect me
or whatever yeah and i think that a lot
of people just stick with that where
they're like you know what it's just one
of those things they're never gonna get
this about me and i'm just gonna stick
with it and it starts to
grate on their happiness and it starts
to over time make them feel very distant
from their partner and then in marriage
you're going through a long time
it gets to a point where you might be
numb and don't feel like there's any
real love anymore but you're like you
know what we made this commitment and
even though the love has graded down to
nothingness
um i know this person they know me and
so i'm just going to stick with it
and i just don't see it happening that
way with me and steve but maybe i'm
naive we've only been together 10 years
so i don't know no and we i mean nobody
wants to wish bad on your marriage it's
amazing but i i do think that in other
relationships i've definitely gotten to
that point of like yeah same yeah i just
have to stick it out it's it's more of
like seeing the positive in each other
like not thinking like he's leaving his
freaking socks there on purpose yeah
yeah right like i don't feel that right
but there's and maybe it's your
personality right and like this is just
my personality but there's definitely
been times where i'm like i need a day
off you know what else it's because you
just moved in together too oh no our
first year together like we were we
moved in within three months of dating
and that is with that first year and i
talked about this a lot it was like we
fought the most like or i didn't know if
it was gonna work out and then we had
like this one day where we like thought
we were gonna break up and everything
like changed where we started
creating a language basically for us to
like get through every single future
argument and we stopped
fighting like we didn't ever have those
type of fights or resentment ever again
because we weren't projecting
different things on each other from like
little things like that where he would
always [ __ ] scratch my pants and i
was getting so [ __ ] mad because like
that non-stick [ __ ] is going to get the
food and it's poisoning the food and i
read a [ __ ] article about it and he's
like that shit's not true i don't think
it snopes it and it's not real and all
this stuff and i'm like it is [ __ ]
real why you gotta always argue with me
about stuff like oh i read an article
you read an article [ __ ] your article
it's my pants it's like yeah don't get
your [ __ ] stuff in my food and he
just wouldn't and it was a respect thing
because they were my pants yeah and even
though they were ten dollar pants or
whatever he's like i'll buy i'll buy you
a new pan i'm like buy your own self a
[ __ ] pan yeah and we'd get so mad
over these pants because
he didn't respect that i said i don't
want you to cut your chicken in my pan
it ruins the pan and it's not about the
pan or the cost of the pan it's about
that you
heard me and you still did it anyway
right and you you're like who cares it's
a pan well it's deeper than a pan it's a
deep dish pan okay yeah um and and we
had to have this whole like once we
learned each other's language we didn't
have fights about the fans anymore
because he understood now that it
actually hurts my feelings that
he
was doing something that i didn't like
about it and he didn't know he was
hurting me he just thought like oh she
wants to fight about a pan i'll [ __ ]
go to war about this pan you know he
likes to debate or they think that it's
just about the pain it's about that he
can't go any deeper than that yeah yeah
exactly and because he had a ex
relationship where she
was just really snobby about like a lot
of things apparently i don't know i
don't know her the relationship but
that's what he says about her
um
he like any time he got a little sense
of someone being like snobby yeah you're
doing this or like something that's not
a big deal and making it into a big deal
he would just like
stick it out like a war over it because
he's like he's not getting run over
anymore right so we realized that we
were like projecting from our previous
relationships and
that was like a really good it was good
that we went through that first year but
i don't know if i would have married him
that first year because that
to me that was not something i could
live with for
10 20 plus years you know i could not
see the rest of my life being with this
person that we're going to bicker over
everything but once we like
discovered that we could be on each
other's teams and like you know we
already knew we loved each other but
they're like solving that issue
i think that makes me feel normal
yeah okay so you did go and i'm not
saying like oh i don't you're not
perfect
but i was like huh like because i've
never felt that with anybody yeah you
know with anybody i've never been like
from day one you were just it no
that [ __ ] was driving me up the [ __ ]
wall and then i guess that's what i mean
is
sometimes i feel like people get married
before figuring that [ __ ] out and
because they haven't figured it out they
let all this resentment build and then
there's nothing there's not even the
love is left and they're just there for
the commitment because they said i said
forever to you yeah yeah i didn't do
that with like long-term relationships
where i'm like oh god
well we might as well stick it out it's
a might as well kind of thing yeah you
know like they know me i know them yeah
nothing's perfect so i guess we just
should stick it yeah and you don't want
to be in a might as well relationship
and i would i would do the same thing
where it's like oh he'll never learn
this it's just who he is you know yeah
no i don't got to deal with that but
then with the same thing with the
article it's like there it got to the
point where they're i was like i would
rather not see him today and then after
we broke up i had like the best night of
sleep of my life wow and that's when i
realized i'm like if someone doesn't
bring
yeah that joy in your life
and peace then this is not gonna work if
they're taking from your life more than
they're adding to yeah that's when you
know yeah like yo
maybe that's not for me maybe we're not
a match yeah yeah and then yeah i
definitely had a that's with the feeling
i had with that guy that had moved to la
that i just had to break up with him
because there was no love left like i
loved him like a brother not like a
romantic partner um
we had been together for five years and
so like it was enough for me to be like
oh yeah i can't spend another five years
yeah with this there's just i don't have
the like
romantic love for you like and when you
don't want to have sex with them anymore
yeah that's a big like that's a huge
sign i even went to a therapist because
i was like if there's any way for me to
work this out
it's just easier to stay together than
it would be to break up because we lived
together all this stuff and she was like
well how about you you know spice it up
in the bedroom and the thought of doing
that made me want to hurl yeah
i don't want to have sex with him
i was like oh yeah that's something you
should want to do with your partner if
you're going to marry them yeah i i
learned that when
uh
when the sex is gone my body starts
rejecting the sex yeah what used to feel
so good now it hurts
you know like i'm not about it anymore
like it burns yeah
it's super weird i i remember seeing on
tick tock where it's like uh like even
your body knows when
he's cheating because you get more like
bacterial and yeast infections oh my god
like i i don't know maybe it's a mixture
of another woman's vagina
or something like that your body
actually knows and it starts like
reacting negatively to it wow that makes
so much sense yeah cause the one guy
that cheated on me i was deaf that i
definitely went through that same
oof ooh i don't want to think it's
because there was enough other it was
dipped in other vaginas yeah i think
it's more like i don't know like
your body intuitively knows maybe the
let's go with that yeah because he would
shower before we have sex and everything
so huh okay so we all know that pumping
gas right now is like a million dollars
a gallon right everybody that's driving
a car right now you are hating it
probably um well good news is that there
is upside well i guess that's the upside
this app is actually so cool guys i i
just started using it and i have gotten
so much cash back from things that i
would normally be doing anyway such as
pumping gas so upside is an app what
you're gonna do is you you open the app
and then it tracks where you are and it
can show you all of the cashback offers
in that area for example i open the app
i hit chevron has a cashback deal where
it's 15 cents back per gallon that means
i'm saving 15 cents per gallon when i
use this offer i click the offer i claim
it and then i go pump my gas i tell them
what kind of gas i'm using you can pick
regular premium whatever and then i
print out the receipt you upload the
receipt and you get that cash back
instantly there's also restaurants you
can get cash back at as well as grocery
stores so you just go to the app and it
shows you all of the offers or you can
sort them by what category you would
like the cashback offers in and then you
save you just save money oh you use your
regular debit and credit cards you don't
even have to open a card or anything
just upload receipts and get cash back
to get started for you though you
download the free upside app in the app
store or google play and use our promo
code big mood and you get five dollars
or more cash back on your first purchase
of ten dollars or more it's so cool so
in comparison to credit card rewards or
loyalty programs you can earn three
times more cash back with upside you can
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon or
other brands whatever you want to do so
you can get your cash back any way you
want upside users are earning more than
a million dollars every week that's
probably why they have 4.8 star rating
on the app store and you can download
the free upside app and use promo code
big mood to get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that's five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more using promo code big
mood get that bag or get your bag back
all right you guys i'm so excited for
this next sponsor bey's luggage ah if
you've heard about bays you know there's
a lot of hype around this luggage and
for good reason because this is some
cute chic amazingly affordable and like
just amazing luggage i'm such a huge fan
so if you guys know me you know that i
travel a lot or i have traveled a lot in
the past i've actually just came back
from a two-week vacation with my
five-month-old i know i'm so crazy i
can't believe i scheduled that
also three destinations we hit and the
entire family were all packing with bays
and it's such an amazing luggage system
i swear last christmas i actually
decided to treat myself and i upgraded
all my luggage to base i got the dopp
kit the mini weekender the check-in the
carry-on two carry-ons actually and i
got a weekender for my son isaac too
like i love this company i also gifted
my sister-in-law my brother-in-law some
base products super huge fan you guys
i'm telling you so base was created by
actress shane mitchell to make sleek and
affordable bags luggage and accessories
designed to help you travel effortlessly
while still looking fashionable baze has
thought of everything you could ever
want in a piece of luggage and i'm
telling you from experience they really
did think of everything 360 degree
gliding wheels a cushioned handle
built-in weight indicator which came in
handy this last trip i barely made it
under the 50 pound limit thanks to the
weight indicator washable bags for your
dirty clothes and all the interior
pockets you need to keep organized their
luggage comes in multiple sizes and
colors i personally have my entire
luggage system in the color beige which
fyi that's what base means in spanish
it's beige which i thought was really
cute and then i have the luggage for my
husband in gray and the weekender in
black for my son and they also have this
new navy color which i think is super
cute by the way i'm telling you i'm a
huge fan and for shorter trips the
weekender bag is super functional and
even has a place to store your shoes
separately my son is loving it i
absolutely love my mini weekender so so
handy i love it every piece is made to
look better with miles so you don't have
to worry about it in cargo or overhead
and base has over 30 000 5 star reviews
and trust me one of them is from me
whether you're packing for a quick trip
or looking to breeze through the
security line base has your personal
items covered right now base is offering
our listeners 15 off your first purchase
by visiting basetravel.com
big mood go to
big
baystravel.com
for 15 off your first purchase that's b
e i s travel dot com slash big mood all
right so the next one is shortly after
waking from anesthesia from a major
surgery and after being administered a
high dose of oxyoxyoxidone
oxycodone oxycodone yes thank you drug
person i was discharged from the
hospital
as we got to my car she turned around
and asked if i wouldn't mind driving and
threw me the keys what
being completely under the influence i
obliged i drove us the 45 minutes home
after the drugs were off i realized
she's not the one i've been through this
when i uh got my wisdom teeth pulled out
october
um i was on the way home and we were
supposed to go to uh arizona for a
wedding right so like on the way home or
like in bed while i was like recovering
from my anesthesia and stuff i was like
did you book the tickets and he's like
how about you help me book the tickets
i've been working all day i was like you
work an office job oof you're a lawyer
like yeah why can't you i'm [ __ ] up on
drugs right now yeah he's like well why
can't you just help so i
drugged out had to book tickets for us
because he couldn't figure it out oh my
god if i can do this drugged up why
can't you or like you're supposed to be
the lawyer dude yeah that knows how to
do things exactly like they just it if
that's and that was just wild to me that
is wild why do i have to do this when
i'm literally recovering from a medical
thing i think it's the thing that you
were talking about earlier too like they
should want to protect you yeah or
provide or like like any reason that
steve could think of to like swing in
there and help like that yeah he'll do
anybody who loves you will do that yeah
and for sure that kind of thing just
like he did what a baby
it just seems childish like we you'd do
it exactly like i've been busy all day
yeah i just got a surgery my mouth is
bleeding bro yeah um i saw a tweet
yesterday uh this nurse she tweeted
she's like um
this woman came into our hospital with a
severe allergic reaction we had to you
know put her in the bed and everything
blah blah blah and her husband just said
okay well i had a long day so i'm going
to go home and sleep call me if you need
me
this is wild now
i can't believe i can't
picture that right like this morning i
started my cycle
sorry men um but i
i didn't know it was coming it's just
been coming at random times now and uh i
had crazy cramps and i was like oh my
god i need milo i didn't bring it i
didn't bring pads that i didn't bring
model i didn't bring anything and like
without me even asking he got his shoes
on he was out the door keys and we're
not at home like we're at a hotel right
now and so he like found he went got
pads middle like he knew everything to
get and just i didn't even have to ask
and i was like oh my god you're my
hero and that's like
that is now like it's not like i expect
that i still am grateful every time that
happens like today i was just like thank
you so much but
it's the thought of him being like yeah
i'm kind of tired right now yeah you
deal with it is like
it's not even in the realm of
possibility yeah and what steve did for
you is not even like wow yeah that
should be the bear
first thing really is comes to people
yes you should be thankful yeah but it
should also be like hey you're my
partner you need something i got you
exactly because it's the same way for
him if he's like for sure [ __ ] like i
can't get out of bed i think something's
wrong like what do you need tylenol you
need
uh nyquil dayquil what do you need uh i
got you mm-hmm
like you should want to do that i saw a
tick tock where a woman she it was like
she had a selfie camera on she was
postpartum just gave birth
and her husband was sleeping on the
hospital bed oh no and she's like he
said he was tired from staying up all
night waiting for me to give birth so he
asked me to move out there so you can
sleep in the bed
and she just gave birth divorce divorce
immediately
yes no and you know what the craziest
thing is that was probably not the first
time he had done something like that if
she's used to that but she was like it's
not gonna get that bad it's not gonna
get girl not till you're like just
giving birth and you're sleeping on your
bed are you gonna be like this where's
the bottom line right where is your rock
bottom because rock bottom should have
been three stops ago yeah right three
incidents ago you're almost to the core
of the earth now you've gone so bottom
yeah if i was that nurse and i saw him
sleep in the bed i would have started
swinging dude you get the [ __ ] out that
man let the woman lay down that's when
the nurses should be mean
i can't even
what was that guy's childhood like that
like the audacity
which then she he must have been used to
that in the relationship too yeah she
probably always let him do whatever he
wanted to
that's just so wild to me yeah that you
would like want like be okay with your
woman that just had your child like
sleeping yeah she was still in the
hospital gown and everything like it was
crazy i'm not even surprised there's
literally
so much wild things i'm gonna get away
with sometimes like for like if if he's
done this and like he's cheated a
thousand times and she's forgiven him
and she was probably pregnant like
bringing in groceries and he was she
probably drove to the hospital you know
so that's totally normal like for him
it's like yeah get up i'm tired yeah
yeah yikes
i know and this is why we need to tell
women they deserve better because you do
yeah and fi figure out those boundaries
before the marriage before the kids
before the house before anything that
locks you guys together shares your bank
account all that stuff you know work all
this [ __ ] out yeah it's like i am baby
that's it
you know like i am always i should be
taken care of because i'm always going
to take care of you from a place of love
yeah you know so i can't even imagine
but good thing we don't have to yeah
true
i do think that like having a little
it's like i microdosed those
relationships in like previous
relationships where it's like the little
bit of entitlement the little bit of
narcissism a little bit of abuse a
little bit and it's like oh oh oh okay
nope i don't think we nope we're not
gonna get full we're not gonna get too
deep yeah with this yeah and i heard you
left before that right yeah and it hurts
because you don't know especially if
those were your first relationships you
don't really know a difference
and you don't know that a lot of your
dating patterns might have to do with
psychological things from your past like
your childhood traumas and you're
subconsciously attracting certain types
of people but when you're if you're
working on yourself and you're you know
seeing a therapist and you're digging
these issues up and you're healing from
them and stuff you will start to attract
healthy relationships and at least then
i had something to compare to so when i
met steve i was like oh
this is what they were talking about
yeah this is the good thing it's a
learning process it is to figure out
like what you're willing to deal with or
not yeah what you want what you need
cause sometimes you don't even know what
you need yeah and that's why i don't
judge people for getting married young
but if you can help it do not get
married young don't get married in your
18 to 25 year old phase that's
just not not a good chance of succeeding
you might you might be one of lucky ones
but you don't learn a lot yet
you haven't learned a lot yet
yeah and a lot of times people will say
like oh but like i want him to do this
and i want him to change and bubba i'm
like look breaking up with him is going
to hurt
but do you want to hurt now or do you
want to hurt when he asked you for the
hospital bed after you just gave birth
because that's gonna hurt too
and that's not even gonna hurt
physically it's gonna hurt like
emotionally
you know so
at the first sign of disrespect
leave before you let him leave and at
that point it's harder to leave because
you you have to put so much time and
yeah you just had a kid yeah you know i
can't i can't believe there's anybody
who would be like the only
the reasonable thing or like the only
excuse why men should be laying on the
hospital bed is if she says i'm
uncomfortable on that bed give me the
couch yeah and then it's like sure let
him lay down on the bed because i want
the couch you know but i don't know how
comfortable those couches are
so
i'm just speaking out of
just guesstimating maybe if he was
having kidney stones at that moment
yeah and then they don't have any other
beds yeah or like his leg fell off yeah
because a machete accidentally hit it or
something then it's okay yeah he could
be in the bed but he's tired because he
was up all night oh okay
yeah okay yeah how many nights you're
gonna be up after this baby well
probably none because oh true she's
gonna make her take care of it
[Music]
yeah girl and this is why women go into
like postpartum depression because they
don't get any help
wow
casey you better help her
in case he's a good one
he can't wait to shout out to the good
dad he was showing us all the pictures
of the new baby good debts are needed
good dads are wanted and needed
okay this one says she told me speaking
of dads she told me she never ever ever
wanted to meet my kids she came up with
a plan that once we moved in together
she could stay at her parents house
during my weekends with them at the time
we only had been together for a little
over a month i broke up with her before
she even took her next breath wow
how could you just make a declaration
like that that earlier you knew he had
kids well here's the thing like if you
don't want to date somebody with kids
that's fine but don't date somebody
exactly yeah don't try to like carve it
out to fit your needs like okay we're
gonna just pretend they don't exist yeah
and i never ever want to meet them for
the entirety of our relationship what
world does this woman think
yeah i can date someone like there's
going to be a man out there that agrees
that
i don't ever need to meet his kids i
wouldn't be surprised if there was a man
that agreed to that but probably not the
type of man you want to do exactly if
you love his kids you would never agree
with that you don't want to do something
like that the only case i can see this
is like maybe a side chick a side chick
maybe wouldn't want to meet the kids
mm-hmm yeah
i mean there's people who genuinely
don't want to date people with kids and
that's okay
you don't get to date people who have
kids yeah and then say we're gonna
pretend you don't have kids exactly yeah
for sure but
definitely
i feel like if you have kids and you're
dating
the first thing you should say is i have
three kids two kids i have a child
they're very important to me like the
one time i dated someone with kids that
was like one of the first three
sentences they said yeah literally like
hi nice to meet you i have my two
daughters blah blah blah they're
beautiful oh okay cool yeah don't try to
hide it yeah because if you try to hide
it then you're part of the problem right
but
yeah i mean good for him yeah that's the
right thing yeah i i knew a chick once
where she got engaged
they were dating for you know probably a
good amount of time she got engaged and
then one morning she
broke off the engagement like the next
time i spoke to i was like how come
you're not engaged what's going on here
she goes
yeah his kids were too loud in the
morning i don't really want to do that
and i was like
well i'm glad they never got married
it's valid it's valid this wasn't the
first time you stayed over this place
and met his kids no maybe she had the
realization like oh i'm marrying the
kids yeah because okay so they say like
when you're marrying somebody you're
marrying their whole family but a lot of
times we think i'm marrying like my
in-laws my brother's in law my
sisters-in-law no worries um but like
when they have kids you become a mom
automatically yeah and you become a mom
to strangers right and you become a mom
to like seven-year-olds 12 year olds 15
year olds you don't become a mom from a
newborn most of the time so i'm glad she
broke it off before yeah and you're
getting compared to their actual mom and
so no matter how good a job you're doing
like you're always being compared yeah
i'm just like any time there's kids
involved
be as honest as possible even in your
sentiments that way like let's say one
morning you woke up and they were being
too loud and you're just annoyed at them
yeah leave
you're doing the right thing you're
doing the kids and uh
you're helping the kids out you're
helping the parent now you're helping
yourself out why would you want to lie
to yourself and be like no i'm just
going to tough it out because i love him
yeah don't tough it out yeah that's so
true yeah i agree with that was the best
time to break it off too they'd only go
together a month
okay i grew out of a certain genre of
music and moved on to other genres that
i reckon she didn't really like she
asked why can't you still like folk and
country it struck me then that she
didn't really love me for who i was she
liked me because i fit this archetype of
what she wanted in a partner and instead
of growing herself she chose to be mad
at me for breaking what she wanted in a
partner she ended up cheating on me with
the dude that i gave my old cds to
oh my god
she just was in love with his taste in
music no way
that's so funny
oh my gosh that's kind of hilarious this
is the weirdest that's the weirdest yeah
that's kind of like it's like a sitcom
episode like a seinfeld episode where
the girl's just like
i'm i was in love with you for your
garden yeah how dense are these people
yeah it also shows that she refuses to
grow and change
in the relationship and grow together
she just follows his disc changer yeah
who has cds anymore too if that's i mean
it's really old no
maybe
oh yeah maybe like they're just stories
from a different yeah when they were
younger yeah that's true
i don't know that's a that's a funny one
to end with uh let us know in the
comments if you've ever broken up with
someone because of one of these reasons
or if you have another silly reason or
maybe i'm bringing up with you because
you just don't do your eyeliner the same
way i don't it's true
my eyes got older
yeah i gave it to i gave it to tiff
actually
go check her out
um follow stacy everywhere she talks
about this a lot on tick tock so follow
her on tech talk we'll put her info in
the description also she has a youtube
channel which talks about other things
her life her wedding that's about to
happen and she's planning and you can
follow all of that uh i guess follow
gina if you want to or me if you want to
whatever go read the show share this
with your friends if they've had crazy
breakup stories definitely share it with
your friends and uh let us know in the
comments what crazy breakup stories have
you gone through oh yeah do that i
really want to read those me too we want
the tea all of it details thanks
okay we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you